حسنًا ، رد المتحدث باسم الكرملين
على كل هذا قائلاً إنهم
يرفضون مرارًا وتكرارًا الاتهام
بأنهم يعتزمون غزو أوكرانيا ، ويقول إن
هذا استفزاز وأن
القوات الأوكرانية ستستخدم الاستفزاز
لمهاجمة
الانفصاليين الموالين لروسيا في منطقة دونباس في  في
شرق
أوكرانيا ،
أخذت المتحدثة باسم وزارة الخارجية ملاحظة أشد قسوة
قائلة إن هذا يُظهر هستيريا في
البيت الأبيض أن هذا يمثل
تهديدات استفزازية مضللة حتى لتغطية
المشاكل في الولايات المتحدة إذا كان كل
هذا يبدو مألوفًا بعض الشيء ، فذلك
لأن  هذا نوع من اللغة
التي سمعناها من المسؤولين الروس
خلال الشهر الماضي في كل مرة تظهر فيها مسألة
نيتهم أو عدم غزو أو
رانيا ويبدو أنها تشير إلى ما
أيناه طوال الوقت الذي لم يفعله الرئيس بو
ين  ومع ذلك ردوا على
رسائل الولايات المتحدة وحلف الناتو التي
تخبره أنهم يرفضون مطالبه
برفض أوكرانيا من الناتو وأن يتراجع الناتو.
بالنسبة إلى مستوياته في عام 1997 ،
لا توجد حركة على مستوى كبار
المسؤولين يقولون إن نفس الخط لا يزال هناك
مساحة أمام الدبلوماسية يتوقع الرئيس ماكرون
إجراء مكالمة مع الرئيس
بوتين في وقت مبكر من بعد ظهر اليوم بتوقيت موسكو
وفي وقت مبكر من المساء ، يجري الرئيس بايدن
مكالمة هاتفية مع الرئيس بوتين.
نيك روبرتسون CNN موسكو